on a daily basis I torment myself over
what you did to my grades the terror and
pain he must have experienced at your
hands as a mother I would have done
anything change place equipment that's
it full of guilt knowing I couldn't help
her that I should have been there he
died terrified and alone confronting her
daughter's murderer just moments before
he was sentenced to life
grace malanez mother couldn't hold back
her tears as she spoke directly to the
man who strangled her daughter to death
in New Zealand ripped a hole in my heart
walked into our lives and destroyed
write your own sexual now my family will
be the same
the 28-year old man who can't be named
for legal reasons was found guilty of
murder in November last year today the
judge sentenced him to life imprisonment
with a minimum of 17 years one of the
longest jail terms in New Zealand's
history you were engaged in the most
personal and intimate of human activity
you are a large and powerful man she was
diminutive and those circumstances ms
Mullane was particularly vulnerable you
were in a position of total physical
dominance it was in December 2018 grace
met the man on a tinder date the night
before her 22nd birthday these were some
of her last moments CCTV footage showed
grace and her killer on their date first
they went to a burger bar and then spent
several hours drinking cocktails before
going to the man's hotel room this is
the last moment
grace Mullane was seen alive in
interviews with the police the man
claimed grace died accidentally during
rough sex I dialed one one that didn't
hit the button and because I was scared
how bad it would
what did you think it looked bad more
it's a dead person my room hours of CCTV
footage was shown in court here the man
visits a shop just after 8 a.m. the
following day he bought a large suitcase
and took it back to the hotel
later that evening he left his hotel
room with two suitcases on a trolley one
of them contained grace malanez naked
body forced into a fetal position
outside court police paid tribute to the
strength of Grace's family the census
today is a reflection of the gravity and
the ongoing impact of the murderers
actions have had not only on the family
but also on people in New Zealand and
the United Kingdom
yeah thoughts of sympathies remain with
Grace's family and friends as I
continues from white to make sense of a
senseless and needless murder grace
Mullane a 21 year old university
graduate from Essex went to explore New
Zealand as a backpacker her murder shook
the country and in the words of her
mother left her family absolutely
heartbroken and living a life sentence
without their grace into mom read Sky
News